bill gates is likely the most well-known
billionaire in the entire world everyone
knows him as the child prodigy that
dropped out of harvard and founded one
of the biggest companies in the world
microsoft since then he's dominated the
top of the billionaires list currently
standing at 112 billion dollars and
that's after donating more than 50
billion dollars to charity clearly
finding microsoft has worked out
extremely well for bill
but bill wasn't the sole founder of
microsoft in fact microsoft was actually
co-founded by another child prodigy
named paul allen and this wasn't just
some honorary title either like apple's
co-founder ronald wayne paul was heavily
involved in the company for nearly a
decade before he decided to part ways at
the time he owned roughly 25 of
microsoft which at the peak would
translate to 625 billion dollars yet
most people have no idea that microsoft
even had a co-founder or that he
tragically died just a few years ago so
here's what happened to the forgotten
founder of microsoft
taking a look back paul allen was born
on january 21 1953 in seattle washington
he was born to a pretty academic family
as both of his parents were heavily
involved in libraries in fact his father
worked as the associate director of
libraries at the university of
washington meanwhile his mom was a
librarian hearing this i don't think
you'd be surprised to hear that his
parents put him in the best school they
could afford a private preparatory
school called lakeside for perspective
annual tuition at the school currently
cost 38 000
aside from enrolling paula in a
prestigious private school his parents
would also consistently take him to
museums galleries and concerts to expose
him to as many interests as possible but
ironically his greatest interest wasn't
any of these his greatest interest was
messing with computers with his friends
from school bill gates and kent evans
this trio would regularly use lakeside's
teletype terminals to develop their
programming skills and soon enough they
would actually found a programming club
the only problem though was that they
didn't have any access to computers so
they made a deal with the local computer
company called the computer center
corporation they offered to find bugs in
their software in exchange for computer
time and it didn't take long for them to
go from this to developing scheduling
software for lakeside
despite spending all this time on
hobbies paul never slipped up
academically either
in fact he got a perfect 1600 on the sat
before being admitted into washington
state university paul was actually two
years older than bill so bill was still
in seattle when paul went off to college
but since paul went to an state college
this made it easy for them to stay in
close contact and work on their first
year's business called trafford data at
the time state and local governments
would often perform traffic surveys in
order to make stoplights more efficient
to accomplish this they would layout
rubber hoses on the road and every time
a car passed by it would create air
pulses within the rubber hose which was
recorded by a mechanical counter paul
and bill's vision with the travel data
was to digitalize this entire process
but they once again had a fundamental
issue they didn't have access to a
computer so they partnered with a man
named paul weiner who could build them a
computer
but just as everything was starting to
get off the ground the trio would be
stopped cold in their tracks the state
of washington would develop their own
traffic processing program which they
gave out for free to local governments
so this unfortunately completely
eliminated the need for travel data by
this point paul had finished two years
of college but when he was offered a job
as a programmer at honeywell in boston
he dropped out and took the job
this was actually perfect timing because
bill would go to harvard at the same
time which is also in boston so the duo
was able to continue their friendship in
boston and it didn't take long for them
to start their next business venture
in 1975 paul and bill would begin
microsoft but the company was nothing
like what we know them as today the
company was actually focused on selling
a programming language interpreter in
new mexico one of their first client
slash partners was an up-and-coming
company called micro instrumentation and
telemetry systems and given that this
company was located in albuquerque new
mexico paul and the bill decided to base
microsoft there as well
it wasn't until four years later that
they would move the headquarters to
their home state of washington in the
meantime microsoft would get some
international exposure as well
in august of 1977 they would form an
agreement with ascii magazine in japan
which allowed them to open ascii
microsoft despite all this progress with
the company it didn't take long for bill
and paul to start developing some
animosity towards each other it all
started with a bill wanting more equity
than palm the argument from bill was
that he was still in college and making
no money but paul already had a
well-paying job
so bill was not only taking a big risk
with microsoft but he would likely be
able to spend more time on microsoft
this argument made sense to paula so he
agreed on splitting the equity 6040 but
it wasn't long before bill wanted even
more equity bill soon renegotiated a
contract to be a 64 36 split paul didn't
want to make a big deal about this and
he knew that both of them would be super
rich anyway if things worked out so he
didn't really fight back against bill
but over time things just got even worse
as microsoft started to attract press
attention bill became the public face of
microsoft which slowly ate away at
paul's significance within the company
the two were quickly growing apart and
they both knew it but paul says that he
was too angry and proud to confront bill
about it though's personality did not
make the situation any better either
according to paula bill was usually an
extremely sore loser and he often had
difficulty admitting his shortfalls for
example paul stopped playing chess with
bill very early on because bill would
often sweep the pieces onto the floor in
anger whenever he lost while such quirks
were likely quite annoying none of these
were enough for paul to leave the
company he was still extremely
optimistic about the future of microsoft
but all of this would change when he
found out that he couldn't be nearly as
optimistic about his own life in 1982 at
age 29 paul would be diagnosed with
hodgkin's lymphoma which is a type of
cancer that affects the immune system
despite this scary diagnosis paul would
stick around at microsoft but his input
into the company was significantly less
for obvious reasons however bill had a
different take on the situation instead
of supporting his friend through this
difficult period bill would start
complaining about how paul was becoming
unproductive and the breaking point was
when paul overheard bill and steve
ballmer discussing how they could reduce
paul's equity after hearing this paul
would do the honourable thing and resign
from microsoft in february of 1983.
fortunately paul's cancer would get
significantly better following his
departure from microsoft but his mental
health was worse than ever before you
see paul didn't really want to leave
microsoft he wanted to be part of
something big and he had already founded
something big but because of bill he was
unable to continue that journey it
should be noted that paul was still on
microsoft's board but this wasn't what
he wanted it per se
so he kind of just wallowed in his own
despair for a few years after leaving
microsoft but all of this would change
when microsoft went public in 1986. at
the end of their first trading day
microsoft would be valued at 780 million
dollars which gave paul a net worth of
195 million dollars paul now had both
loads of money and a life-threatening
disease that could return at any time so
i don't think you'd be surprised here
that paul decided to stop feeling sorry
for himself and started living it up
while he still could but before he did
that he wanted to start off with a
positive task
so in 1986 he founded the paul g allen
family foundation which was dedicated to
advancing health and human services
after this however paul started
splurging he of course bought all of the
classic things like mansions yachts
private jets and sports teams but he
also had several creative indulgences as
well for example paul was a massive fan
of music and especially rock music so in
2000 he opened the experience music
project which was a rock and roll museum
that was dedicated to his rock hero jimi
hendrix he also created his own band
called the underthinkers where he sang
it and played a guitar in 2013 he
launched a full album in which he
personally wrote or co-wrote every song
in the album aside from music paul also
began collecting really unique items for
example he built up a collection of
world war ii fighter planes he also had
an extensive art collection that was
filled with pieces that were worth tens
of millions each paul didn't just spend
all of his money though he also invested
significant portions of it for example
he had stakes in america online and
dreamworks his sports bets also ended up
playing up pretty well as he owned the
seattle seahawks the portland
trailblazers and the seattle sounders
the seahawks would end up making it to
the super bowl three times and they even
won in 2014
not all of his investments went so
smoothly though paul definitely had his
fair share of losses which in his case
were massive one of his investments
charter communications held for
bankruptcy while many of his other pet
projects including asymmetrics star wave
metrocom and interval research never
lived up to what he envisioned
nonetheless his stake in microsoft and
his other successful investments were
more than enough to make up for these
given that he would end up with a net
worth of 20 billion dollars
in terms of paul's relationship with
bill gates after the fallout they did
eventually make amends and get back onto
a talking basis but it was never quite
the same paul stuck around on microsoft
sport up until 2000 at which point he
left as bill gates stepped down from
being ceo
unfortunately paul's lymphoma would
resurface in 2009 and it though he would
get treatment he was no doubt getting
weaker and weaker as paul saw the end of
his life approaching he decided to write
a memoir called idea man that told the
story of microsoft from his perspective
in the book he claims that it was
actually him who came up with a bunch of
the ideas that bill gates often gets
credit for for example paul says that he
was the one who came up with the name
microsoft and that he created a soft
card and that he was the one who thought
of targeting the personal computer
market according to paula he was the one
that came up with all of the ideas while
bill spent most of his time running the
business itself many critics have
pointed out that the book is filled with
bitterness and that it's more of a rant
than an inspiring memoir but none of
that really matters though as paul's
lymphoma would return yet again in 2018
and it would take his life on october 15
2018 at age 65. in terms of what will
happen to his 4th gen paul never got
married and had no children so he
doesn't have any errors that will take
over paul's goal was to simply donate
all of his money after his death and he
wrote a detailed plan regarding how to
do that so all that's left is for his
sister jody allen to actually execute
his final vision he was never able to be
the leading voice at microsoft but
hopefully he will be the leading voice
regarding the future of his fortune
would you guys rather be rich and sick
or poor and healthy comment that down
below
also drop a like if you agree that paul
allen is underrated and of course
consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing and see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you